hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today were going
to be going over a game between a
dolphin Anderson and kazursky Adolf
Anderson being one of the top chess
grandmasters in the late 1800s because
their ski also being a very formidable
chess master himself now this is called
the immortal game you've probably heard
other grandmasters have their own
immortal games but this is the e mortal
game this is kind of where it all
started so you know as far as chess
history this is right up there at the
top but it's an amazing game and also
it's a very aggressive game so for those
players out there that love to play
aggressively love to sacrifice you're
really going to enjoy this game one of
the reasons I like this game so much is
because Anderson decided to play the
Kings gambit line which is a very
aggressive opening it's my favorite
opening and it really allows you to
attack your opponent very frequently and
all throughout the game just trying to
go after the king as much as you can so
anderson started with pawn to e4 black
responded with pawn to e5 and anderson
right away offers up his pawn sacrifice
here on f4 and he does this for two
reasons he really wants to wrap a
development at the same time after black
takes white really has control of the
center of the board this pawn here on e5
from black was kind of controlling these
dark squares on d4 and f4 black no
longer has control of the center of the
board now keep in mind white is down a
pawn in material but a lot of times he
can make that up later on in the game
now white here can continue in two ways
the main line is to bring his knight to
f3 simple development movement at the
same time getting closer to castling his
King on the Kings side
Anderson chose the other option that's
bringing his Bishop to c4 giving his
minor pieces involved in the game and at
the same time attacking this key
weakness here on the f7 square now black
does have a couple options from here
Kaiser deed chose to bring his Queen to
h4 now you don't see this too much in
today's chess games only because it
really leaves your queen exposed later
on in the game you're really going to be
having your queen chased around but
still a lot of players will play Queen
to h4 because the king is forced to move
to
f-1 can't bring his pawn to g3 because
then black could take it with this pawn
and if you retakes obviously this is
going to be very bad for white his
entire King side is just completely
blown up
so from here white is forced to bring
his King to f1 so black basically has to
choose if he wants to bring his Queen to
h4 and have it chased around the board
in return for white not white is no
longer going to be able to castle on
either side of the board now in this
situation black really has three moves
he does have the Brian counter gambit
with pawn to b5 which was played in the
actual game trying to force this
LightSquared Bishop off this long
diagonal that's attacking this key
weakness on f7 or black could have
played pawn to d6 which I prefer opening
up you know his LightSquared Bishop into
the game or he could have brought his
minor piece in right away with Knight to
f6 but in any case kazursky decided to
play pawn to b5 which i think is the
weaker of the three moves after white
takes both sides are equal in material
but as you can see this pawn here on d7
is now pin down to the King so this is
going to be a thorn in black sides for
some time now now black did decide after
this to go ahead and play Knight to f6
developing a minor piece you always want
to develop your minor pieces towards the
center trying to control the center of
the board and from here wide it was only
a matter of time Anderson played Knight
to f3 attacking the Queen here on h4 and
gaining a tempo the Queen is going to
have to you know move back and lose a
move here so the Queen comes back to h6
now white really has two moves here you
can keep in mind here this pawn here on
e4 is hanging a lot of times you want to
develop your minor pieces so he could
have easily brought his Knight to c3
simple development moving at the same
time defending this pawn here on e4 or
his other option which was played in the
game is to bring his pawn here to d3
what this does not only does it support
this pawn on e4 but it also opens a
discovered attack on this pawn here on
f4 from the bishop so both of those are
completely fine anderson decided to play
pawn to d3
from here kazursky played Knight to h5
and he did this for a few reasons one it
allows his queen a few spaces for
breathing room obviously the night here
on f6 is kind of blocking off some of
the spaces that the Queen can go to at
the same time it's defending this pawn
on f4 and it's also threatening Knight
to g3 which is a strong move not only
checking the king and the rook but if
this pawn here from h2 were to capture
then the rook would fall to the queen
here on h6 so anderson obviously saw
this in he played Knight to h4 which is
a fantastic move not only blocking the
threat on g3 but at the same time
getting ready to bring his Knight to f5
gaining a tempo attacking the Queen once
again and also having this nice little
outpost on the f5 square now black now
brought his queen to g5 logical move not
only attacking the knight here on h4 but
also attacking the bishop here on b5
this Bishop on b5 is really a thorn in
black side he really wants to start to
develop on the Queen side and move this
pawn here from these 7 so the Queen to
g5 is attacking both of those now
Anderson can just continue with his plan
bringing his Knight to f5 not only
having his knight safe but at the same
time you know blocking off the bishop on
b5 to be captured now from here would
have been you know the best move if
guisard he would have played pawn to g6
you know kicking off this night here on
f5 because this is a strong outpost for
the night here on f5 but kazursky did
not instead he played pawn to c5 excuse
me pawn to c6 again really trying to get
this bishop out of the way so that the
pawn here on d7 can start to push up the
board and try to counter as far as
center control is because right now
black has no center control
great thing about Anderson and he
continued to attack the entire game even
when his own pieces were being attacked
he decided to counter-attack on the
other side of the board and that's
exactly what he did in this case
Anderson played pawn to g4 attacking the
knight here on h5 now keeping
and that black could play office on this
is a legal move here but keep in mind
that his Queen would be hanging from the
bishop on c1 so this was not an option
for black instead he decided to go ahead
and move his knight back so he brought
his knight back to f6 kind of retreating
here at the same time he is still
putting pressure on this bishop here on
b5 great move from Anderson he decided
to now bring his rook to g1 here
obviously he would have liked to right
away
play his pawn to h4 starting to attack
you know the Queen but the Queen and the
knight are both attacking this pawn on
g4 and so the Queen could just come down
and take this pawn right away
Anderson knew this and solve it right
away he could bring his rook to g1 and
yes he is sacrificing his bishop on d5
but he can already start to see the
limited spaces that the Queen has to
move it's going to be very good for
white very bad for blacks this is
exactly what he played rook to g1 and
black decided to go ahead and take the
bishop on b5 trying to gain as much
material as they can and he tries to get
his Queen to safety now Anderson
continued with his plan he brought pawn
to h4 and again the black king is forced
to move and he only has one place to
move and that is to g6 so white
continued to push up the board with pawn
to h5 and the only move again black has
here is Queen to g5 now that Anderson
starts to have all his pieces in place
as he wants them and he starts to kind
of have this Queen contained he starts
to get some of his other pieces involved
in the game he now brings his Queen to
f3 as you can already see he's now
attacking this pawn right here and in
any given time he can bring his bishop
to f4 and the Queen's going to be left
hanging there's nothing the Queen can do
for black to not be taken so obviously
kazursky sees this and he knows that he
has to move his knight now he has to
give his his queen some breathing room
or he's going to lose it on the next
turn so he decides to bring his knight
to g8 there's really no other good moves
he can't bring it to d7 he can't bring
it to d5 or it would be 10
taken and again he can't bring it to g4
or h5 without being taken so he does
bring it back to g8 but you can RDC
after white now comes and takes with his
bishop on f4 if you kind of look at the
setup here yes Black is up in material
because he did take the bishop from
white here on b5 but all of whites
pieces are on the back rank here besides
the Queen that's just being chased
around the board and why it's slowly and
slowly controlling the entire center and
he's starting to develop all of his
pieces on the board so as you can
already see it's starting to kind of
shift for Anderson's favor because black
just has none of his pieces developed
and the pieces that he does have he's
under developing them back to the
eighth-ranked here black doesn't have
any other options he continues to have
to run away his queen and this is again
why you don't see at the beginning of
the game that Queen to h4 checking the
King yes it does force the King to move
but as you can see here a very wise
Kings game at player that's very
familiar with White's opening line is
going to have a fun time just chasing
your Queen around the board the entire
game so from here white decided to
continue and finish his development with
Knight to c3 all of his minor pieces are
in the game his rooks here are as
connected as they're going to be because
white cannot castle at the same time he
does have his queen out in the game so
as you can see here white is completely
controlling the center of the board here
so black really needs to start to
develop his pieces kazursky decided to
bring his Bishop to c5 he would really
like to get his other Knight involved in
the action he could bring his knight to
e7 or some sort of play like that castle
on the Kings side get some sort of King
side safety because again he is up in
material but his King is kind of in the
center of the board and he's very
vulnerable right now
but kazursky decides to bring his Bishop
to c5 very logical move for development
at the same time attacking this rook
here on g1 what black doesn't quite
understand is that these rooks aren't
really doing too much for the attack but
all these minor pieces in McCoy
mean they have a strong attack that can
come later on in the game but this is a
very simple development move and it you
know it's not a bad move from here white
decided to kind of counter play instead
of moving his rook here he decided to
bring his Knight to d5 long time ago
when I was learning chess I always heard
if the King is in the center for your
opponent and all of your pieces are in
the center attack attack attack
especially if you're playing the Kings
gambit line you don't play the Kings
gambit line to play a passive game
you're really trying to attack attack
attack and so that's why Anderson in
this situation played Knight to d5 yes
he is attacking the Queen here on f6 but
even more importantly he's attacking
Knight to c7 check you know forking both
the king and the rook they're on a8 and
at the same time the King still in the
middle and he's just waiting to be
attacked here from here black decided to
come down and capture on Queen to b2 and
white here had a fantastic news probably
the the crown jewel in the game here so
if you want to pause and take a minute
see if you can come up with the move but
it's Bishop to d6 and really what this
does is it it threatens a lot of
different mating opportunities for white
but it's sacrificing both of the rooks
here obviously you can see the rook here
on G ones hanging along with this you
know taking with Queen to a-1 checking
the King on f1 why it's basically giving
up both of these rooks here to bring his
Bishop to d6 here now it probably would
have been a lot smarter if Queen came
captured on a1 first and then after
black moved to e2 black can outcome to
be too obviously threatening taking on
c2 gaining a tempo yet again so anderson
would be forced to bring his king to d2
and now the bishop could come down and
take on g1 unfortunately this is not
what was played in the game probably
would have been better for black but
black decided to go ahead and play
Bishop takes on g1 and after the bishop
came down to g1 this is kind of the
dagger in the coffin the pawn now came
to
five and what this does from white it
does one simple thing but it's huge in
the game because it now restricts this
Queen here on b2 to get into the game
this queen can no longer defend the king
up here it's only a matter of time
before Anderson can just completely
dominate as far as checkmate in the King
it's in the center of the board and he
has all this pieces pieces in the center
of the board to attack the King from
here black decides to bring his queen to
a1 and after the king came to e2 a lot
of people say that kazursky actually
resigned in the game right away
partly due the fact that it's been said
that Anderson announced the the mating
moves in the game which I always think
is kind of funny if you're playing a
master on the chess board just in the
middle of the game to say you lost and
just say let me show you how I'm about
to beat you and then just have your
opponent just forfeit I think that'd be
really funny but to show what the actual
mate that was announced is we'll go
ahead and continue on the board black
brings his knight to a6 and then white
has a very nice mating net here he
brings his Knight to d7 attacking the
King here the King only has one move
bringing his King to d8 and now just to
kind of add salt to the wound brings his
Queen to f6 black is now forced to
capture with his Knights and now the
bishop can come to e7
checkmate so a fantastic move if you
look at it white is down a queen two
rooks and the bishop and material at the
same time was able to win a game against
a very strong master here so this is a
fantastic example of how attacking
sacrificing can go well for you
obviously it can go bad sometimes but if
you have a strong attack especially if
your opponent's king is in the center of
the board you know you can continue to
attack and good things can happen so
hopefully you guys enjoyed the immortal
game one of the greatest chess games
ever played obviously that's you know
debatable what the greatest game is ever
but this is the mortal game so hopefully
you enjoyed hopefully you learn
something if you haven't already
you subscribe and I'll see you guys in
the next video